Speaker 1: OK, let's try Eric from Cancun now.
Eric, happy new year. I want to. I want you to
get right into your question because, you know,
we've struggled with that in the past, my friend.
Go right into it. What's your question today?
Speaker 7: Hmm. Hi, David. I will read you
something I agree with in your read says.
And those Republicans can't be trusted and
the party of majority. If they're not, they
didn't use cartoons as real world examples
also became friends with cartoon characters than
I did, because Republicans can either be envious
or intimidated that Sesame Street and have a
higher moral levels than them. Let's not forget
that Marjorie Taylor Greene went to portray
the Green New Deal as a Scooby Doo monster.
And when Fred wasn't asking the monster, the
culprit was communists and the incidence of
attack on Titan, do you remember?
Speaker 1: Well, Eric, I have no
idea what you're talking about. Did you just
read something or is that something you wrote?
Speaker 7: It is something I growth in this court.
It's about Republicans wanting to use cartoons as
real examples for politics. You remember when
Marjorie Taylor Greene went to portray the
Green New Deal as a Scooby-Doo monster?
Speaker 1: I don't remember that.
I don't remember that. No.
Speaker 7: And they were using
mincing Dean in the Senate floor.
Speaker 1: I remember memes on
the Senate floor, yes, that I remember.
Speaker 7: Yeah, it turned down. And they were
picking fights with Dr. Seuss and Sesame Street.
Speaker 1: Yes, I remember that.
Speaker 7: And I can I don't think they
wouldn't be mature enough to focus on
real politics is they're using cartoons as real
world examples. I mean, and some that would be
the job of politicians and actual cartoonists
and not in those whom we trust with the loss.
Speaker 1: That's an
incredibly astute observation,
Eric. Eric, how is the weather in Cancun?
Speaker 7: And now it's sunny, it's a bit cold,
but they like it in winter and summer. And who do
you think they would go after next, like Disney or
Cartoon Network because they belong to Ted Turner
and he made Captain Planet or My Little Pony?
Speaker 1: I'm not sure Eric Eric from Cancun
always unblemished. Every phone call is absolutely
perfect. I really appreciate hearing hearing from
you. Wow, that is really, really something else.